- I'm not interested in
judging people's hustle.
I'm interested in telling
people how I've accomplished
what I've accomplished
which is I don't think
I'm that talented.
I do think
I've outworked people.
I think that's real.
I also think it's controllable.
And I think anybody
who's watching right now
they may not be the
most talented entrepreneur
or salesman or an
amazing craft of content
but if they outwork
somebody that is a variable
that feels in control.
Somebody who wants to
start a YouTube show
if they do it 365 days a
year versus somebody
that does it 137 days a year
and they're equally as talented
the person that does it 365
is gonna win.
I mean that's just the truth.
And it's the only practical
advice that I think I can give.
Go get more talent.
I can't say that.
But, you know, work harder
and go to less happy hours
and don't watch entire
seasons of "House of Cards,"
yeah, that feels real and so,
to me, I think it's amazing to
take the whole month of
August off in Europe.
I think that's amazing
work life balance
and for many people
that's the right advice.
It's just not my little
narrow view on the world
in the concept of
if you complain
about what you
want professoinally
well, there's a way to fix it.
If you're content and
you make €55,000 a year
and you have all of August off and
you're a part of the dart team
and you spend tons
of time with your kids
and you're content and
you do not complain
well then you're a hero to me.
(light music)